for the first time ever apple has
released
four new iphone models now including
the iphone 12 mini so i can say with
absolute certainty that it's never been
this hard to decide which iphone you
should actually buy
especially since we also have the 400
iphone se
that's still a great deal so what i'm
gonna do in this video is show you guys
the real world differences and recommend
each iphone
for different use cases helping you
decide
which iphone you should buy but before i
get into the buyer's guide portion of
this video
i want to go through 12 different
mistakes that you must be aware of
so you can avoid them when buying a new
iphone so let's get started with
mistake number one don't buy the iphone
12
pro models thinking that you need them
for the best 5g coverage
the fact is that the regular iphone 12
and even the 12 mini
have the same 5g support including
millimeter wave 5g and everything else
like wi-fi 6.
so don't spend the extra cash on the pro
if that's all you really care about
mistake number two is buying the iphone
12 mini without
considering the battery life impact this
phone is
super small in fact smaller than the
iphone 6
so if you really care about battery life
i would steer away from the mini model
and just pay a hundred dollars more for
the larger iphone 12.
mistake number three is buying the
iphone 12 pro models thinking you need
them for the better display
water resistance or the thinner design
what's really shocking
this year is that the regular iphone 12
gets
the same exact super retina xdr
display with 1200 nits of peak
brightness and the same
crazy good 460 pixels per inch the only
downside is that in typical
usage it's limited to 625 nits
compared to 800 that's it and in terms
of water resistance
the regular iphone 12 models get ip68 at
6 meters
for up to 30 minutes exactly the same
resistance as
the pro models which wasn't the case
last year
since the iphone 11 only had 2 meters of
ip68 and what's even more surprising is
that the regular iphone 12 models have
the exact same thickness as
the pro models 7.4 millimeters
which wasn't the case last year since
the iphone 11 was really thick
at 8.3 millimeters mistake number four
is buying the iphone 12 pro if you want
the absolute
best camera quality the iphone 12 pro
max
gets massive camera improvements
including
a much better main camera sensor that is
47 larger and improves low light by a
huge 87 percent
it also gets the brand new sensor shift
stabilization feature which is going to
make for super smooth video
and sharp photos and it gets an improved
telephoto lens
with a longer 65 millimeter zoom
compared to 52 on the 12
pro so definitely buy the 12 pro max if
you want the absolute
best camera quality and it's great that
it's only a hundred dollars more
for mistake number five if you're
planning on buying one of the regular
iphone 12 models
don't miss out on the crazy good value
storage
upgrade for only 50 dollars more
you get double the storage up to 128
gigs
which is a must if you take a lot of
photos and video
i currently have the 11 pro max with
only 64 gigs of storage
and it's nowhere near enough so i
definitely recommend
that 50 upgrade for the regular models
mistake number six
is considering buying the iphone 11 pro
model
for less cash now that the iphone 12 is
out
and my answer is a very strong no even
if you can find
the 11 pro brand new for 800.
absolutely 100 buy the regular iphone 12
model instead
because it's got almost all the same
features like the oled display
but it gets even better camera quality
it's got much better
cellular service it's quite a lot
thinner and it's got the new design with
the flat sides
which should be staying around for the
next few years
so even though it's missing a couple of
features like the telephoto lens
absolutely buy the regular iphone 12
instead of the 11 pro for mistake number
seven
don't buy third party wireless chargers
for the iphone 12 lineup
you might not know this but only
branded charges from apple and other
companies like belkin
get the new 15 watt fast wireless
charging
and on top of that these new chargers
support the cool
mag safe magnetic feature so you can
actually use your phone
while it's wirelessly charging the issue
with other third-party chargers
is that if you don't get the placement
perfect you might wake up to a battery
that hasn't charged at all
and magsafe solves that mistake number
eight
also has to do with max safe and if
you're interested
in that feature do not buy a regular or
common
third party case apple added extra
magnets into
all of their new cases because there's a
good chance that the magnetic connection
isn't going to be strong enough to hold
on to other accessories
if you use a basic case so if you want
to buy one of the new magsafe adapters
or even third-party accessories
like a magnetic pop socket buy a high
quality
apple branded mac safe case but if you
don't really care about that
i'm gonna have a couple of great case
options down in the description below
now for mistake number nine this one
hasn't really been confirmed just yet
but according to a bunch of leaks
including leaked benchmarks
there's a good chance that the iphone 12
pro models will actually come with six
gigabytes of ram
while the regular 12 models only get
four for some people
this is a deal-breaking feature if the
pros actually get
6 gigs making it more than worth paying
extra
for the pro models and in my experience
4 gigabytes of ram on the 11 pro
just isn't enough because apps like
facebook would randomly close on me
so double check the ram to confirm
before you buy
for mistake number 10 if you need a new
charging brick
due to apple taking it out of the box do
not buy
apple's 20 watt power brick instead you
should buy anker's
20 watt fast charger on amazon for two
different reasons
one it's currently on sale for only 16
if you use the coupon code and number
two
it's much smaller and more compact
compared to apple's version
which is quite a bit larger so i'm going
to leave a link down to the anchor
charger
down below for mistake number 11 if
you're using verizon or
t cellular service be sure to actually
choose
those options during checkout instead of
buying it
unlocked since it'll save you 30 dollars
on the regular iphone 12 models
and if you notice this little bit of
fine print only the att models are
actually
locked so verizon users have no reason
at all
to choose the sim free version so don't
do that on accident
or you're going to be paying an extra 30
dollars for nothing
and finally for mistake number 12 if
you're not
planning on spending at least a thousand
dollars for a new iphone
don't wait until next year to upgrade
thinking that you're gonna get features
like 120 hertz promotion that feature is
almost certainly
only coming on the pro models and in my
opinion
i think there's going to be even less of
a difference next year
compared to everything we got with this
year's regular iphone 12.
with that let's get into the buyer's
guide portion of this video
and i'm going to start with the iphone
se which is priced at 399
this phone is really meant for three
different kinds of people
number one is for people who want a fast
budget iphone
like people switching from an android
phone number two is for kids or
teens since the size is small and the
price
is very low and number three is for
non-tech enthusiasts
who are upgrading from an older iphone
since the sc
is very familiar with the home button
and touch id
and upgrading gets you a fresh battery
and
a new fast performing chip now moving on
to the iphone 12
mini these are the people who should be
buying this phone
if you want an iphone 12 for the new
design the great camera quality
5g and other features like mac safe
and you want to get it for the absolute
lowest price
you've gotta go with the mini since it's
699 dollars
on top of that if you're someone who
really loved the smaller iphones like
the iphone 4
you're gonna love the 12 mini since it's
so small
so it's great for people with smaller
hands and the best part is that the
feature set
is identical to the regular iphone 12 so
the only downside
is lower battery life due to the smaller
size
now for the regular 6.1 inch iphone 12 i
think it's gonna be
the star of the show because it packs an
incredible amount of value
compared to the pro models just like i
said before
the iphone 12 absolutely destroys the 11
pro
and in terms of value it easily beats
out the iphone 12 pro as well
in fact the 12 pro literally only gets
8 advantages the stainless steel sides
the telephoto camera 800 nits typical
brightness on the display compared to
625
the lidar scanner potentially six gigs
of ram
128 gigs of storage instead of 64.
the apple pro raw feature which isn't
available yet
and dolby vision recording at 60 frames
per second
instead of 30. that's it because of that
i think most people looking at the
iphone 12 pro
should just go for the regular 12 since
you could save 200
or 150 if you want to get the same 128
gigs of storage
on the iphone 12. we recently ran a poll
asking people which iphone 12 model
they're going to buy
and the 12 pro was by far the least
popular option and that's because it
barely improves
on the regular iphone 12. moving on i'm
actually going to skip ahead to who
should be buying the iphone 12 pro max
before i finish off with the regular 12
pro first off the 12 pro max gets the
absolute
best camera performance on any iphone
with a much better
main camera sensor that's larger and it
gets the new
sensor shift stabilization feature and
of course
the longer telephoto lens for better
zoom shots
so if you really care about camera
quality buy
the iphone 12 pro max for sure and we'll
be testing the camera differences
very soon so subscribe right now if you
haven't already and looking back at that
poll that we ran
most people wanted the max model and i
can guarantee you
it's because of the camera improvements
other reasons to go for the pro max are
of course the massive 6.7 inch display
for immersive
media consumption and gaming you're also
getting the best battery life
due to the larger size and of course
you're getting the other advantages like
potentially six gigs of ram
and the lidar scanner so if you're
considering buying the iphone 12 pro
just go for the pro max instead because
you really get a lot of camera
improvements
for the extra hundred dollars but of
course not everyone wants
the massive pro max so let's finish off
with who should actually buy
the 12 pro if you care about camera
quality and you really really want
that telephoto lens and other features
like pro raw
the lidar scanner and things like that
but the pro
max is simply way too big for your hands
then sure go for the 12 pro but other
than that
there are really only three reasons why
anyone should buy the 12 pro
over the less expensive iphone 12 model
the first reason
is if you really care about ram since
the pro models are most likely coming
with six gigs
compared to four and to some people
that's a deal breaker
the second reason is if you really enjoy
the feel of the premium
stainless steel band compared to
aluminum and if that difference is worth
it for you
then get the pro and the final reason is
if you're a t-mobile customer like
myself
who has to pay an extra 30 dollars for
the regular iphone 12
and you also really want at least 128
gigs of storage
at that point the difference in price is
only a hundred and twenty dollars
which could be worth it for the few
bonus features you get on the pro
now with all of that said if this video
helped you make a decision
go ahead and click the circle above for
our hands-on comparison videos
coming very soon and if you're still
wondering which one you should buy or if
you should upgrade
comment down below and i'm gonna do my
best to help you make a decision
and if you're still struggling check out
one of those two videos right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
you